can i work out on my period is it
dangerous
what exercises should i do when on my
period
what should i avoid that's what i'll be
answering in today's video
when we're on our period our uterus is
shedding its lining for crying out loud
so it's no surprise that we have to deal
with bloating
mood swings cramps fatigue and
indigestion
we just want to cozy up on the sofa
rather than working out i
totally get it ladies but what if i told
you that working out
during your period can actually help
relieve
some of the period symptoms and make you
feel better
exercising while on your period can
increase endorphins the feel good
hormone improve your mood ease menstrual
cramps
reduce cravings keep your hormone
imbalance and as a result
this helps to regulate irregular periods
naturally
yes you should exercise on your period
saying that however
there are also certain types of
exercises which we might want to avoid
depending on how your body feels here
are a few
do's and don'ts
some ladies think that because they are
low in energy and experience discomfort
they should just lie in bed and do
nothing that way
the pain will go away and they will feel
better this is
not the case i'm sure you'll just be
tossing and turning in pin
and you might even pop some peels to
help
i know it's tough but do move even if
it's a short
10 to 15 minutes of stretching or
walking i promise you it's going to make
you feel so much better
and it will reduce your period pains and
discomfort naturally
so get up get out of bed and do some
light movements to boost your mood and
energy
i love interval running it's really
effective in burning fat and building
endurance
however it is a very taxing workout
and all that high impact rapid movement
in your lower body
might aggravate your menstrual cramps
and leave you feeling
completely wiped out this is not the
time to add more stress
and fatigue to your body instead your
workout should make you feel
more energized
choose light cardio exercises such as
taking a 30 minute brisk walk outdoor
walking at a steady pace for an extended
period of time is a great cardio
which also promotes fat burning without
making you
extremely fatigued if however you can't
go outdoors at the moment
then do try out my indoor walking
exercises which you can do
at home and get your steps in
i do understand that it can get really
frustrating to some ladies because
you feel like it's affecting your
training progress due to the changes in
our hormones
our joints and tendons are at a higher
risk of injuries
when we're on our period so it's not a
great idea to be trying out
new exercises or lifting excessively
heavy weights
without a spotter for support for some
women including myself
i find my training sessions to be much
more challenging
and i do struggle to lift heavy saying
that however
you should not skip strength training
you can reduce your training volume and
also weights if you need to
take slightly longer breaks in between
sets and maintain your heart rate at a
steady pace
some research has found that strength
training during the follicular phase
results in a higher increase in muscle
strength
compared to training in the luteal phase
so don't miss
strength training just take it down a
notch
if you're feeling extremely tired and
experiencing menstrual cramps
this is not the time to be adding more
stress
to your body by doing high impact high
intensity training
or running half a marathon this could
actually do
more harm to your body and even cause
exercise induced
inflammation be realistic with yourself
and listen to your body
change things up and engage in gentle
low intensity exercises
such as yoga and pilates there are lots
of yoga poses which
actually helps to increase blood flow
and circulation
which helps your body to relax reduce
cramps
reduce breast tenderness reduce muscle
fatigue
and soreness this is the time to do
movements that will help
rather than harm your body
fitness enthusiasts i do understand that
this could be hard to do because
we want to do our best in every training
session however
this is not the time to subscribe to the
no pain
no gain idea if you feel extremely
fatigued
nauseous or experience an increased pain
or discomfort
stop what you're doing and take extra
time to recover
if these symptoms continue stop
completely don't force yourself and push
through listen to your body
be realistic with yourself and listen to
your body
vary your workouts take extra time to
recover
avoid over exercising and honor what
you're capable of
no taking it easy on one workout session
will not hinder your progress you have
been making overtraining
will we're all different and the period
symptoms i have
will be different from you if you're not
experiencing
any discomfort from your period then
feel free to continue with your regular
exercise routine
if you find that your body isn't
performing like it used to
give yourself a break ease up on the
intensity
and vary your workouts the key to
exercising when you least feel like it
is to do something you actually enjoy so
ladies do you experience period
discomfort
let me know in the comments below if you
find this video to be useful then give
this video a thumbs up
share this video with your girlfriends
and do
move even when you're on your period
okay hit the subscribe button and do
check out my youtube channel for a lot
more
workout videos nutritional tips as well
as healthy recipe videos and i will see
you next time
all the best